[Music]
thank you so much for being back here I
want to start by saying there gonna be
some spoilers so if you are not caught
up on Game of Thrones you may wish to
keep the show on this channel don't turn
or turn to another one but maybe cover
your ears okay that would be good that
would be good or mute they couldn't mute
yes yes oh you can well actually most
people watch my show on mute anyway my
voice has been proven to be highly
irritating I'm going to start by saying
that in in one of the most recent
episodes again Game of Thrones did not
disappoint you made a bold move and you
killed King Joffrey
and another wedding
it was another wedding you better win
your weddings are awful every time you
have a wedding on your show 30 people
died horribly you know we established
that right in the first season was a
Dothraki wedding any wedding but that
doesn't have at least three deaths or so
visibility right yeah no one's going to
invite you to one that's for sure
but I'm curious I think King Joffrey I
was trying to think about it I can't
think of a character people have hated
more on he was absolutely awful did you
have any mixed feelings at all about
killing Joffrey or were you were you
cool with it well of course I killed
them years ago in the books yeah so at
that time we didn't actually have an
actor playing him or something
Jack Gleeson who played Joffrey was
actually like the nicest guy in the
world ever there was it I can't imagine
that I can't imagine when you see that
character and he's always saying things
like what's a nice little cat it's been
hard to believe that he's a really nice
guy as an actor I think it's a good
thing I wrote the books before we
started making this show because when
you when you make the show and you
actually meet the actors then it's
harder to kill them because oh I'm gonna
make jack we'll be out of a job then
right and it seems so nice and he told
me he's buying a boat that's where I
don't want to kill him what I've done
all the killing years ago so I don't
have to worry about it right the show is
just trying to catch up to the murders
you committed years ago
that's true to be fair David Benioff and
Dan Weiss who who are the showrunners
they're killing characters who are still
alive in the books so as as bloody as I
am David and Dan are always turning
things up to 11 so really no one is safe
even even the book readers who say wow
this characters
he's not any trouble because he's still
in book 5 me have an unpleasant supplies
what now is that an unpleasant surprise
for you when you wrote the book and you
really loved this a character and then
they put a spear through his mouth you
know is that I know about it because I
actually work on the show and break one
episode per season usually so I have a
little warning but I do kind of squeal
when I get the outlines oh wait a minute
wait a minute he's not dead in the books
right still alive in the books like this
is TV pal sit back and relax the actor
asks for rays we had to do something
they wanted air conditioning in their
trailer they're dead
this must have been I don't know how you
felt about this must been a thrill at
the White House Correspondents Dinner
about a week ago President Obama in his
in his routine referenced the Iron
Throne in the game of Thrones
that's right and and you know we would
we would gladly give him one we have
about six or seven of them we gave one
to a guy and brooklyn recently you know
you give these away well they did they
had a big season four premiere at the
Barclays center seven thousand fans were
there and we drew a seat number so a guy
from Hoboken won and Iron Throne Wow
there's a guy in Hoboken spin
I mean Iron Throne
Pizza will be ordered if I want one of
those I'd cut a hole in and put right
over the toilet I guess I think we have
I just keep imagining the guy trying to
get it home on the path tubes that makes
me wanna I want to get one from the show
we have left into an episode of this
show where it's the same exact show but
I'm on an iron throne the whole show but
just is engaging in celebrity banter and
then Andy can use it as a toilet what we
should take a look at because it was
really fun when President Obama
referenced your show let's take a look
this year I promise to use more
executive actions to get things done
without Congress my critics call this
the imperial presidency truth is I just
show up every day of my office and do my
job got a picture of this I think
[Music]
[Applause]